fight hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to let's play
ragdoll Olympics now there's so much
explanation for this one you kind of
just gotta play it so that's what we're
gonna do as you can see I'm a guy with
no bones here good duh
my only regret as I had bone-itis and he
was born with a condition that somehow
made him this elastic jelly man and you
gotta toss him so that yeah haha I
haven't even begun starting and I'm
already winning and you got to toss him
in order to win these super awesome mega
events as you go along your day trying
to win the Olympics so as you can see in
100 yeah I don't even need to try I'm so
good I should just go ahead and join the
Olympics already it's just about the
same as this right oh I was doing this
on the last one and I didn't even avert
a little bit yeah can't stop me now the
long jump I mean how do you win this one
I'll screw you buddy
I haven't even begun to try and I can
tell by the intense graphics that are
hang on
give me a tick I'm not I'm not over that
line just yet just hold on to your tits
they're comically well did I loser win
you kind of said both fair fight rest
what what hi hi you bring it on here
I'm not wait okay I want apparently I
have no idea what I did or why I did it
but I won yeah super extra triple
awesome super somersault and perfect
dive how I kind of bounced off of them
there is no water there but I think I
won yeah take that buddy I screw you
that is you can't fool me that is the
high jump bar you ah screw you buddy
hang on you gotta hang on give me a
second here flip you know what screw
this I'm coming over there I'm gonna get
y'all now I've gotta getcha I'm gonna
thrust my hips out yeah that's how I win
all of my fights
I didn't even move I'll just turn into a
turtle here and then you'll never beat
me
haha I've got
you now ha ha ha whistling again huh oh
hey buddy how's it go on there nice nan
bones you have there up how am I gonna
get over without Oh No what stuck
together oh the people shouldn't be
watching this oh oh oh no no no my love
they're fine Fahd watch now god damn it
god this isn't fair I'm trying to get
the ball I'm an expert ball handler and
yet I cannot defeat this game now ah it
was still on my belly you are such a
son-of-a-bitch game you know that right
you know that right
you are a giant bag of asses you're a
bag of asses and then there's a bag of
dicks over there on the other side of
the net and each all really come on oh
no don't go that way
you Steve how did that happen no
everybody look at this see how my line
is going up into the right somehow I
went to the lab how does that make any
sense
yah ha ha ha ha Delhi way I lose I am
too pro watch me ah tae ha ha ha I hate
this game get it get it get it get a get
a get a get a get a get a get a get a
get a get a get together get together
get together ha ha ha this isn't [ __ ]
possible ha ha ha no I haven't it's
right there go right tell me yeah yeah
yeah I did it somehow Oh God not soccer
what's the [ __ ] hell get all the
balls all the balls
yeah that one was easier oh my god you
gotta be joking me let me win some that
guy is stuck oh no I shoved the ball up
his ass I I don't know what happened the
ball is now gone huh nah there's that
why are there three teams excuse me turn
in my way ha ha ha what's up [ __ ]
hell yeah I won somehow I I did it a
good job everybody
marathon get out of my way I've got to
win the marathon by using my flying
technique Hey
don't be jelly don't be jelly of my
skills here yeah ah for my home country
I have got to get off of my podium I am
over here I dominate you know you know I
like you I like you you're third place
that means your question well yeah
that's how it into a ball nah I'm now
come told myself into it I live near I
think I am dead I think maybe wait no
what where am I going wait where am I
going